ok this is a pepper panic saga level 3
28 walkthrough tutorial this is a level
that gave people a lot of trouble you
have to match alternating patterns you
have 16 of them they're orange and
purple and all those peppers are trapped
in these crates and show you what that
looks like they're located here the
Purple's are at the bottom and the
oranges are at the top and then you have
them spread out on in the middle so
that's where they all are so the first
thing you have to do is just clear the
crates as fast as you can we got a
couple good matches here to get things
started
and this level takes a long time so I'm
not going to talk too in-depth then I
want to make the the video really long
but at first you just kind of want to
clear the crates out and try to set up
something at the top to get the orange
to get an orange match
even though i don't need the Purple's
yet I'm going ahead and clearing out the
bottom a little bit so go ahead and make
an orange match
that will set up this purple
so as long as you have some peppers that
you can match the first couple aren't
that hard it gets more complicated as as
it goes one thing to keep in mind is
each time you match the number of purple
and orange is fixed so you starting to
match new ones a fall so you want to
keep and eye on where these end up at
the top
and you'll get in the situations like
this where you can't really make any
matches at the bottom but since crates
now can be taken out by explosions you
can see that if we could we could get a
yellow chain reaction going then we'll
be able to clear out a bunch of the
bottom one so we'll go ahead and do that
see our purple ones where they're at
that will get most of our peppers
exposed
alright so now we need an orange again
we have one orange is still trapped and
then we have our other oranges all
spread around so I just want to try to
move things into place
and I think this is where people get
into trouble is everything spread out so
they don't know what to do if there's no
matches available then you really don't
have a choice but to try to switch
things up
I look towards the bottom of the board
first because that's going to cause the
most action that when you
you don't have anything that you just
sort of work at the top
you can see that it's slow going at
times but you'll eventually get it if
you pay attention
I guess the main thing at this point is
just try not to make any matches for you
know just for no reason like actually
try to try to have a purpose behind your
matches
you can see slowly but surely we're
getting the ones we need
all right here here we're pretty spread
out with the orange
we've also only got seven moves left so
good to try to be pretty strategic here
and you always have to watch because you
know new ones were going to fall so
and that's pretty much it that's how you
do it where's our last one right there
so it can seem really really difficult
but the main thing is to just you know
clear your crates are really look for
setups if they're not there then you
know rearrange the board as fast as
possible and it's not easy to do but if
you will if you watch back in the
beginning to where the peppers are at
you know where they are to start so just
take your time don't get too frustrated
if you have any questions leave a
comment hope this helps thanks